das geht so herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video in dem wir heute mal ein
paar fax mit der welt die long seite
indem wir heute im padam bord maps
spielen werden und nebenbei ich euch
eine geschichte erzählen werde denn ein
neuer tag ist ein neuer tag wenn man
nicht mindestens einmal sein leben
riskiert so wie ich heute und ich möchte
kurz erzählen wie das heute bei mir
passiert ist und alles klar wir spielen
hier scheinbar klein bisschen blindheit
das bild begann alles damit dass ich
einfach zwei jahre lang als ich nun zwei
jahre lang über zwei jahre lang ist von
meinem neuen zimmer in seinem studienort
und ich hatte einfach zwei jahre lang
einen lampenschirmen beim zimmer und
einfach nur eine nackte glühbirne
das will ich auch mal vorstellen weil
ich so vollkommen und sie hasst ich bin
wenn es im inline richtung geht das ist
mir vollkommen egal
und dann irgendwann dachte ich mir
kommen junge du brauchst lampe und habe
ich mir richtig gehören leute ich hab
mir richtig getrennt und mein ganzes
geld ausgegeben für ein lampenschirm von
zwar für ein von ikea für sage und
schreibe 90 zehnten klassen dieses teil
hier was bisschen aus dem todesstern 95
verhältnis falsch mache ich mir gedacht
und es wäre nicht gekauft dazu kann dann
aber auch noch ein kabel weil ich mir
dachte okay ich brauch noch 'n lampen
aufhängen wird schon so eine kleine
aktionen dingsbums da was hat das wasser
an die decke kommt sowas weißes da seht
ihr jetzt auch hier gerade oben
sowas hier ja dieses weiße plastik teil
ist übrigens alles noch nicht fertig
montiert er so komisch aus so auch im
fall dieses kapital kammer zu aber das
war zu lang
deswegen muss dies kürzen also was habe
ich gemacht ich habe keine ahnung von
elektrik oder so und es bestimmte
draußen irgend jemand von euch der eine
ausbildung zum elektriker macht oder so
jetzt sagen kann ob ich heute mein leben
wirklich gefährdet habe oder nicht auf
jeden fall was hier als solist platte
auf jeden fall habe ich dann die alte
leitung mit der alten glühbirne der
alten fassung durchgeschnitten auf meine
haushalts schwere die alte durchschnitt
leitung sieht dann so aus hier zeigt die
habe ich durch geschnitten dass sie also
lieber dran abgeschnitten und das kabel
von der neuen die dann der waldeckischen
abhängen sehen seit megalan also habe
ich das noch mal gekürzt
jetzt sieht man da drin
ein blauer in braunau draht wir müssen
euch das vorstellen habe ich mich auf
mein bett gestellt ja ich stand auf
meinem bett auf dieser wackligen
matratze und schneidet das weiße hier
auf weil da auch ein blauer und brauner
drin sind und dröselt es irgendwo
auseinander und nehmen dass hier
und beides auf und verwurzelt irgendwie
die blauen braunen dreht ineinander
natürlich nur eine frau mit braunen blau
mit blauer und das alles an einer
leitung die halt mehr oder weniger
direkt am stromnetz hängen und ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen obwohl ich die
sicherung raus gemacht habe vorher habe
ich mich echt ein bisschen mulmig dabei
gefühlt weil ich dachte mir ich weiß
nicht ob das ein kind kann kann die
spannung von die an der glühbirne hängt
einen umbringen
wer ganz gut war so wissen so im
nachhinein auf jeden fall habe ich mich
so gefühlt als könnte es nicht umbringen
lassen okay was ist jetzt wenn ich jetzt
ab kratze keine youtube-videos mehr
alles klar
das ging mir durch den kopf und ich war
wirklich mulmig dabei weil ihr müsst
euch das game ja da kommt ein kabel aus
der wand wie schneidet das auch mit der
haushalt schwere also quasi alles was
ich als kind beigebracht wurde was sie
nicht machen sollte und ihr macht
trotzdem
und alles nur um einen neuen
lampenschirm zu haben dachte ich mir
auch so muss das wirklich sein soll ich
nicht lieber aufhören will ich das am
ende auf einem grabstein steht er ist
dabei gestorben ein 90 cent ikea
lampenschirm aufzuhängen
er hat auch nicht so geil aber das ist
auch schon das ziel wieder aber ich
hab's dann am ende gemacht also ich
hätte wirklich davor kabel kommt aus der
decke es besteht aus einem wackeligen
brett mit einer schere und schnippelt
daran rum und mit einem messer um die
isolierung irgendwie abzustellen und
verwurzelter die drähte ineinander und
das der knüller es leute der absolute
oberknaller ist dass ich am ende weil
ich kein isolierband hatte ja ich hatte
keine isolierband aber man muss sie
dreht isolieren dass sie nicht einander
kommen weil sonst stellen vorbei ich
habe dann einfach weil ich kein
schwarzes isolierband hatte also kein
schwarzes klebeband mit dem man
normalerweise elektrogeräte abdichtet
habe ich fucking heft sticker also das
sind beschriftung sticker dessen so
kleine labels die man normalerweise auf
heft oder ordner packt um zu wissen was
drin ist habe ich genommen und damit die
drähte isoliert und ich bin ich mir fast
zu 100 prozent sicher dass wir die
konstruktion um die ohren fliegen wird
und
irgendwas zumindest mal abbrennt wenn
nicht schlimmer ich was ich musste ich
noch mal zum baumarkt aber er ohne wird
es irgendwann für euch da draußen
elektriker und kann er kann bestätigen
dass diese konstruktion nicht
lebensgefährlich ist wer hat dich cool
weil ich heute abend in dem bett schlafe
was und halt meter diese bühne ist und
wenn dir unter kraft und mich umbringt
wäre nicht so geil ist wir es sehr
unterhaltsam zu einem gewissen punkt
aber ich werde wahrscheinlich nicht
filmen können weil es mich einfach in
meinem schlaf gerissen wird nicht nur
einfach glauben ja damit habe ich heute
vormittag verbracht und ich hab mich
wirklich die ganze zeit dabei so gefühl
das kann ich jetzt jeden moment
abkratzen ich hab natürlich getestet ob
die sicherung wirklich raus ist als ich
geguckt ok nachttischlampe geht da der
strom geht es schon mal am pc oder so
aber es ist immer noch ein komisches
gefühl wirklich würde jetzt sagen macht
es selbst mal aber ich würde ich nicht
empfehlen weil am ende geht auf jeden
fall einer drauf was aber ist echt
seltsam das kann ich euch sagen ein
kabel kommt aus der wand und wirklich
dann erinnert man sich an die ganzen
sachen die mauern papa einem in der
kindheit immer gesagt haben so wenig an
die kabel am kabel rum schnippeln es
ganz blöd und dann bist du aber irgendwo
keine ahnung erwachsen aber so da sollst
dir wird erwachsen sein und musste den
eigenen lampenschirm aufhängen und eine
neue lampen fassung und dafür dass
hubble durch sein muss muss sich das
kabel bob durchschneiden war das
wirklich nötig oder habt ihr einfach nur
gerade in sonst mein leben aufs spiel
gesetzt könnte auch meine kommentare
schreiben
so oder so die neue fassung hängt jetzt
mehr oder weniger da ich bin aber
trotzdem nicht ganz zufrieden ich muss
morgen auf jeden fall nochmal zum
baumarkt ist ihr letzter denke ich mir
so ich bin casey leisten kann alle
selbst bauen
aber ich bin es halt einfach nicht ich
muss morgen auf jeden fall nochmal zum
baumarkt in isolierband kaufen wir noch
von irgendwem der qualifiziert ist eine
bestätigung dafür ein dass wir das ding
nicht um die ohren fliegt nicht die bude
abbrennt wenn ich jetzt bei meiner
familie bin in den nächsten tagen wer
ganz leis auf jeden fall pro
altersklasse hat kann auch ein laufender
not und unter auflagen
basit
warum die leute das seltsame ist einer
ganzen sache war dass man einfach weiß
okay und man war eigentlich man weiß es
nicht man hat das gefühl dass man sein
leben irgendwie aufs spiel setzt weil
man irgendwelche elektronischen treten
rum schnippelt und dann denkt man sich
so ok wofür stehe ich jetzt eigentlich
alle darauf dafür warum dafür dass ich
ein lampenschirm in der bude habt und
die ganze sache ein bisschen schöner
aussieht ist es das wirklich wert
und dann das beste ist dann denke ich
mir trotzdem so auch hollo bollo
gestalten dass trotzdem mal darum und
das sollte man vielleicht lieber nicht
machen also leute nehmt euch da auf
jeden fall kein vorbild an mir
am ende ist es gut ausgegangen die
sicherung ist ausgeblieben ich habe
keinen stromschlag bekommen und davon
ist das ziel
hierüber ich realisiere jetzt gerade
nach elf minuten aufnahme dass ich die
ganze zeit in sound aus den boxen hatte
nicht auf den kopfhörern
alter schwede wie kann man sofort schild
sein so oder so danke fürs zuschauen und
schreibt man die kommentare wenn ihr
irgendwelche fragen zu der geschichte
habe oder wie es generell findet wenn
ich so eine story erzählen für jetzt
cool wollen nicht so cool
würde mich mal interessieren in diesem
sinne dann bis zum nächsten video drei
macht's gut und